[Musique]
bonjour merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette nouvelle édition du club de la
presse sur tv 78 la chaîne des yvelines
émission retransmise aussi sur l fm
radio 95.5 aujourd'hui pour
m'accompagner sur ce plateau à kimaya
bonjour bonjour rédactrice en chef de l
fm à vos côtés alexandre marquer bonjour
bonjour responsable du secteur de
saint-quentin pour toutes les nouvelles
également présent sur internet le cette
suite actus.fr et puis grégory canale
bonjour bonjour l'injecteur en chef
adjoint de tv 78 au sommaire du club de
la presse ce mois-ci hôpitaux étudiants
avocats cheminots la contestation bat
son plein et tous les secteurs semblent
concerner réforme des retraites mais
aussi nouveau baccalauréat et manque de
moyens au coeur des revendications ne
reviendrons aussi sur la création de
l'université paris saclay nouvelle étape
franchie avec l'intégration officielle
de l'université de versailles saint
quentin en yvelines depuis le 1er
janvier
autre fusion ou celles des
hauts-de-seine et des yvelines 2020 sera
t-elle l'année décisive et puis les
tensions au plus haut entre le
département et le cimentier calcia qui
envisagent de déplacer une partie de ses
activités avant de refermer ce club de
la presse nous verrons aussi quelles
sont les personnalités du mois à
l'honneur notamment la présidente d'une
association mobilisée pour l'australie
nous sommes le 31 janvier nous débutons
ce club de la presse avec l'actualité du
mois l'actualité principale de ces
dernières semaines c'est bien évidemment
cette colère sociale les lycéens
bloquent les établissements pour
exprimer leur mécontentement face aux 3
c ce sont ces épreuves communes de
contrôle continu qui remplace l'examen
final du bac ils se disent mal préparée
il ya eu des mobilisations à limay à
guyancourt aux mureaux également les
services hospitaliers qui dénoncent un
manque de moyens et puis réforme des
retraites manifestations dans plusieurs
villes dont versailles on a vu les
avocats qui est en colère on avait les
cheminots aussi qui se mobilisaient est
ce que vous sentez cette seconde
générale au nord du département à climat
oui absolument
ça le département n'est pas ne bénéficie
pas d'un microclimat donc effectivement
on ressent aussi toutes ces
mobilisations vous on a vu quelques
images effectivement du côté de chez
nous sur l'e-mail mantes la jolie
on a pu voir les mobilisations de
certains lycéens dans bon nombre de
lycéens et aussi de près de 50 % des
enseignants du côté de limay au niveau
des mobilisations
effectivement on a vu on a eu une
retraite aux flambeaux
c'était le jeudi 23 janvier dernier donc
effectivement une mobilisation qui
continue et dont on ne voit pas on sent
qu'elle sait qu'elle ça se calme mais
mes a priori nouvelle journée est prévue
le 6 février prochain
donc ça continue ça perdure bien dans
les yvelines alexandre marquer vos
quêtes sur versailles juste on voyait
les et les images de versailles la
mobilisation des avocats tous les jours
il ya une mobilisation sur versailles
mais c'est étonnant ce qui étonnant je
demanderai ce que ce que disait hakima
c'est que on a l'impression que le
mouvement est en train de s'essouffler
un peu notamment à la ratp la sncf et
c'est à ce moment là en fait que la
contestation la pris une tournure un peu
différente plus radicale on a
l'impression avec un durcissement un peu
à la manière des gilet jaune avec des
mouvements effectivement des actions
tous les jours et des catégories
vraiment complètement différente quand
on a les avocats le personnel
hospitalier les lycéens les enseignants
c'est ce étonnant est très sympa d'une
contamination de corporations en
corporation est effectivement là on
arrive ça a été l'élément déclencheur un
peu c'est aussi cette mobilisation
contre les retraites aujourd'hui tout le
corps de métier les hôpitaux aussi un
qui dénoncent un manque de moyens et
même des démissions aussi qui ont été
annoncées au sein des hôpitaux des
démissions et d'une lettre commune qui a
été effectivement signé par plusieurs
médecins pour démissionner voilà face à
ce système des retraites on parlait
aussi way de mobilisation tous les jours
on a cité les avocats ya la cgt
cheminots ziki tous les jours tient une
assemblée générale
en gare de versailles chantiers donc une
mobilisation tous les jours donc il ya
commencé avec cette réforme des
retraites et c'est vrai qu'à la rentrée
on parle de ses 2 3 c ces épreuves de
contrôle continu du baccalauréat avec
mobilisation enseignante mais aussi les
lycéens qui se mobilisent pas mal qui
dénoncent notamment un manque
d'information ils sont prévenus au
dernier moment en tout cas c'est ce que
je dis aux établissements et qui
bloquent leurs établissements notamment
lycée de villa roi a dût en cours qu'on
a vu à l'image et avec ça on n'a pas vu
venir les lycéens avec c'est arrivé
comme ça et puis tout d'un coup du jour
au lendemain à travers les réseaux
sociaux ils ont commencé à se monter là
dessus ça s'échanger entre les
différents lycées puis tout d'un coup
c'est sorti la début janvier depuis
effectivement on a des lycées qui bloque
quasiment tous les jours quand les
agents villard plaisir villard web
oui plusieurs lycées et puis avec un
point d'interrogation sur le sort de ces
lycéens qui n'ont pas pu passer leurs
épreuves puisque c'est une épreuve qui
étaient censés compter pour l'examen
final
il risque 2 0 à cette heure-ci donc une
mobilisation engagée de la part de ces
lycéens puisque quand on prend le risque
de d'avoir une note négative à l'examen
c'est aussi un signal aujourd'hui il ya
beaucoup de zéros qui circule sur les
réseaux sociaux entre les examens les
héros sur les feuilles de revenu de
salaire aussi de certains cheminots qui
commençait mobilisés depuis plusieurs
mois nié des faits que c'est pour les
non grévistes
oui c'est vrai pour parler de deux jurés
de conflit on a l'impression qu'ils
aient une contestation sociale en tout
cas depuis longtemps et on parlait des
cheminots qui avait démarré à l'été 2010
8 contre la réforme de leur statut les
gilet jaune oti forcément l'été dernier
c'était aussi il y avait une
contestation au niveau du baccalauréat
une grève des notes qui avait été opérée
par les profs et là c'est vrai que ça a
repris on va dire en intensité avec
cette grève contre la réforme des
retraites donc c'est vrai qu'on a
l'impression qu'il ya une contestation
sociale en tout cas qui qui dure et qui
dépasse même les syndicats syndicats
qu'on reçoit régulièrement sur nos
antennes hakima pour pour l fm vous avez
reçues sur votre émission état civil le
15 janvier dernier des représentants
syndicaux absolument et l'ambiance
était assez tendue je dois je dois je
peux vous le révéler à l'image de ces
derniers jours des crispations on
on comprend liés à aux divergences
portés par leurs syndicats respectifs
sept cfdt cgt c'est bien ça voilà donc
c'était le 15 janvier dernier pour
situer la date avec vincent guérin le
secrétaire général de l'union
départementale cfdt des yvelines nicolas
lévesque secrétaire de l'union locale
cgt des mureaux et puis eric bezou un
cheminots syndiqués au chai et sud rail
à monte dans les coulisses du studio
juste avant l'émission ça ça a clashé
vous le dire pour le dire clairement les
échanges étaient assez vif entre le
représentant départemental de la cfdt
qui a été pris à partie par eric bezou à
tel point que l'émission a failli ne pas
se faire quand même
donc on parle pas de nom était là avec
des mitaines amont précisons les
coulisses il ya pas eu de clash allons
passer chez nous à long terme par contre
à l'antenne la raison a pris le dessus
finalement l'émission a pu a pu se
dérouler même si vous le verrez dans
l'extrait enfin on le verra peut-être
pas forcément puisque ce n'est qu'un
extrait il n'y a pas eu de dialogue en
principe cette émission c'est une
émission un petit peu débats échanges et
là c'était questions réponses et ça a
été les conditions pour permettre cette
cette émission en tout cas ils ont
réussi à exprimer leurs points de vue
respectifs d'ailleurs il me semblait un
petit examen il écoute cet extrait de
l'état civil du 15 janvier dernier sur l
fm après plus de quarante jours de grève
le conflit peut-il durer
eric
nous on espère qu'il va durer jusqu'à la
victoire il faut qu'ils durent jusqu'au
retrait de cette réforme parce que cette
réforme c'est l'arbre qui cache la forêt
derrière il ya tout le reste et y en a
déjà qui sont passées puisque nous qu'on
est motivé nous les cheminots voilà on
l'a prouvé maintenant faire un appel
aussi aux dons faut que la caisse de
grève se remplissent
si on veut que la grève continue si 68
60 % des français sont contre cette
réforme ce qui est apparaît dans les
sondages et bien que chacun donne au
moins 1 euros dans la caisse de grève
des cheminots et on tiendra et on fera
tomber cette réforme des retraites et on
stoppera l'ailé les vilenies le
gouvernement est juste après avoir si la
six a pas cette réforme des retraites
après c'est la sécu qui passe on sait
très bien pour la cfdt l'insensé la fin
du conflit
nous nous restons mobilisés pour pouvoir
négocier au mieux et peser ces
négociations la cgt en tout cas va tout
faire pour faire tomber cette réforme
cette réforme c'est une c'est un choix
de civilisation c'est le choix de la
ddea l'isthme contre la solidarité et
ont des contre ça la cgt est à l'origine
de la réforme de l'heure de la retraite
de la sécurité sociale avec le cnr que
ça dit gouvernement par ses évocations
qui sont aurélien ces fonds se moque du
monde
il crache à la tête de tous ceux qui ont
construit ce ce système et on poursuivra
jusqu'au retrait avec ou sans les
regrets concours suivra on poursuivra et
on poursuivra jusqu'à gagner des propos
engagés ils sont fermes malgré tout
suffisante avec ses musiques détendu
derrière ça passe très bien mais
directement de s'entend très bien
c'était le secrétaire de l'union locale
cgt des mureaux on l'entendait qui
exprimait une grève à durée indéterminée
mais n'ont ni des fermes d'opposition
effectivement là sur les missions que ça
s'est calmé mais vraiment on sent qu'il
ya de réelles
norel crispation et une violence
contenue à dire au niveau local sur dix
âgés sont tout à l'heure sur le fait que
la mobilisation s'essouffle mais qu'en
tout cas il ya une poignée de personnes
qui restent déterminés à poursuivre le
conflit on l'a entendu on a entendu dans
leçons qu'on voie lactée soit au niveau
local et aussi sur paris puisque le
le mouvement du mantois effectivement
étaient présents sur le cortège parisien
donc il ya une mobilisation de toutes
les corporations sont se mobilisent
aussi de plus en plus même si le
mouvement s'essouffle comment dans
l'opinion c'est perçu quel retour vous
en avez sur le terrain est ce que les
gens s'habituent à cette grève est ce
que les gens en ont marre de cette
mobilisation aussi que ce soit aussi
dans les écoles ce soit pour prendre les
transports
alexandre j'ai pas trop de retour là
dessus mais une certaine habitude qui se
prend voilà l'instruction et les gens
sont habitués à prendre le train à être
dans la galère mais non nous dans les
idées non on émissions passées du en
fait on
nous ce qu'on ressent et puis moi moi
pour reprendre les je prends les
transports donc je vois les gens je les
trouve au contraire à ses patients
on a l'impression que ils ont passé le
plus dur
et vu que ça va mieux maintenant même si
tout n'est pas réglé
ils sont un petit peu résignés et puis
ils sont plutôt favorables comme f&a et
craintif vis-à-vis de cette réforme donc
il n'y a pas de grosse opposition et
puis de ras-le-bol des face à cette
grève historique ont parlé des
différents syndicats qui étaient
mobilisés des salariés qui sont
mobilisés
le medef aussi quelquefois a exprimé
quelques réserves vous avez pu le
constater sur le sur le plateau du débat
la semaine dernière grégory on a on a
reçu effectivement le nouveau président
du du medef yvelines qui s'interrogeait
notamment sur le financement l'équilibré
financier de cette réforme des retraites
on rappelle qu'il ya une conférence sur
le financement et qui s'est ouverte
actuellement pour essayer de trouver des
solutions au travers des partenaires
sociaux essayé de faire 100 cet âge
d'équilibré c'est vrai que zachary a
redit le nouveau président du medef
civile exprimaient dé quelques voilà
quelques
on va dire quelques contraintes sur sur
cet aspect du financement parle de flou
aussi on va écouter un extrait également
c'était lors du débat du 29 janvier
dernier sur tv 78 disons qu'il ya
beaucoup de flou et le vrai problème de
cette réforme c'est ça c'est qu'il ya eu
deux années de négociations ou de
discussions
le medef en général lorsqu'il a été
consultée pendant ces deux années
il n'y avait jamais des réponses
précises les premières précisions sont
arrivés dès que le premier ministre
avait pris le dossier en main
donc ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point j'ai entendu dire leur
présente aux drm dire qu'il allait
toucher aux réserves qui ont été
accumulées particulièrement par les
régimes du secteur privé et des
indépendants nous cette démarche elle ne
convient pas pourquoi une réserve en
général et les fêtes pour les coups durs
eu un écroulement subi de la croissance
un trou d'air il faut avoir des réserves
pour pouvoir je dirais y répondre et
maintenir les retraites d'aider des gens
en retraite mais nous verrons bien
comment ça va se poursuivre ce différend
ces différents mouvements entre temps
rappelle aussi qu'il ya des élections
même si elles ne sont que municipal pas
nationale y aura peut-être une
contestation aussi qui va s'exprimer
dans les ions donc on le verra bien je
devrais juste pour terminer cette
séquence consacrée à cette mobilisation
qui perdure en montrer l'originalité de
certains il ya eu 1
l'un des avocats mobilisés sur
versailles qui a posté une petite vidéo
sur les réseaux sociaux que totalisé pas
mal de vue regarder
on
au fait graves
alors pour ceux qui nous suivra la radio
se précise qu'il s'agissait donc d'un
avocat d'un des avocats mobilisés sur
versailles qui a décidé de faire un show
un saut en parachute et donc ils se
filment juste avant et qu'il ya une
pancarte avec marc et danse mobilisation
la colère des avocats on précise on n'a
pas vu la fin de la vidéo il avait bien
un parachute ce qu'on peut dire ce sont
les avocats c'est qu'ils en sont à leur
quatrième semaine de grève mairie et que
du coup les affaires commencent à
prendre énormément de retard reçoit
plusieurs centaines il ya beaucoup de
retard on se demande comment ils vont
pouvoir rattraper ce retard
rappelons que je pense leur adresser la
palme de l'originalité ils ont fait
aussi une chorégraphie en m'élisant pulp
fiction la scène mythique entre john
travolta et uma thurman devant les
grilles du château de versailles pour
attirer l'attention milieu toute cette
contestation ont passé on reste des
autres informations de l'actualité
locale et dans le reste de l'actualité
que nous abordons ce mois ci dans le
club de la presse l'université paris
saclay l'université de versailles saint
quentin en yvelines est désormais un
membre associé
gregory c signifie quoi alors ça
signifie donc ça c'est complexe
alors l'univers c'est paris saclay est
créée au 1er janvier donc il ya trois
universités qui la composent dont
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines qui est pour l'instant vous
l'avez dit wilfried un membre associé
c'est à dire que elle siège au sein de
cette université paris saclay tout en
préparant sa fusion en 2025 il n'y aura
plus d'universités versailles saint
quentin en yvelines et sera totalement
fondu au sein de cette grande université
paris saclay en rappel juste l'ambition
de cette université c'est peut-être la
première université française de figurer
dans le top 20 mondial par exemple dans
le classement de shanghai est c'est une
université juste pour rappeler les
chiffres qui comptera à terme 80 mille
étudiants et plus de dix mille
enseignants chercheurs donc on va dire
membres associés c'est un processus
temporaire pour préparer cette fusion
totale qui aura lieu en 2025 et qui aura
une incidence sur tout le département
parce que des antennes de l'université
de versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines
même si le nom c'est versailles saint
quentin et prochainement paris saclay il
y en a partout dans le nord du
département dans le mantois s'il ya un
nom du théâtre et mantes la jolie
vélizy et à sciences po à saint germain
en laye c'est vrai que cette université
paris 7 versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pardon qui
deviendra paris saclay est assez étalée
dans le département ils sont devenus
l'université des yvelines on peut le
dire aujourd'hui véritablement et avec
un poids qui va s'affirmer 1 1 puis le
président de versailles-saint-quentin
université de versailles saint quentin
étaient en plateau il ya quelques jours
aussi on l'écoutera à propos de cette
fusion ce rapprochement avec paris
saclay la création de l'établissement
qu'on avait établissement expérimental
université paris saclay qui manoeuvrait
universités dans laquelle lu vs qu a été
tout au long a construit co-construit
est l'aboutissement finalement de
plusieurs années de synergies et de
collaboration qui a eu entre les
différents partenaires élus vs que iv
demande est déjà largement engagé dans
cette université et donc il ya beaucoup
de nos diplômes surtout diplôme de
master 80% de nos diplômes de master et
la totalité des diplômés de doctorat qui
sont déjà mutualiser et ses
enseignements au lieu ces formations le
surnom sur notre sur le territoire sur
nos campus et qui sont délivrés par
arnaud d'autres enseignants alors
finalement le résultat est plutôt beau
aujourd'hui pour cette université pour
ôter pourtant il ya quelques années on
parlait de fermeture avec son marketing
pas si lointain où c'était très tendu
pour l'université heureusement elle a
repris 1 a repris son chemin en avant et
là effectivement on parler d'elle dans
les 20 meilleures universités mondiales
sait quelque chose
donc oui l'objectif c'est de bâtir un
miti à la française c'est parce qu'on
dit souvent
en fait l'objectif c'est de mutualiser
les moyens et de d'espérer attirer ainsi
les meilleurs étudiants pour renforcer
la réputation de l'université à
l'international et d'offrir un diplôme
en fait qui seraient reconnues au niveau
international et profiter de cet élan
qui est en train de se créer sur le
plateau de saclay avec la ligne 18 qui
est arrivé le l'ambition c'est vraiment
d'en faire on disait un émail si on
parle même de silicon valley à la
française
ce plateau de saclay c'est oui c'est de
profiter aussi de cet élan qui est en
train de se créer ici avec après en tout
cas quelques inquiétudes aussi qu'ils
sont tout de même - et donné parce que
la question aussi c'est est ce que tout
le monde aura cette âme accès à ces
études laquelle poursuite d'études
certains syndicats sur l'université
versailles saint quentin paris saclay
évoque un système peut-être à deux
vitesses avec des licences débit licence
lui sélective master et doctorat qui
seraient pas ouverts à tous il ya aussi
ça qu'il faudra faudra suivre voir si il
ya une égalité d'accès d'ailleurs pas
lancé le sondage mais même sur une
sélection au sein de l'université
ils ont pensé quoi ah bah l'université
s'est concrètement c'est là où il n'ya
pas de sélection normalement c c'est je
pense que je sais pas la sélection à
l'université moi ça me paraît dérisoire
médias hakima oui c'est un sondage en
temps réel et non en même temps en même
temps peut-être que pour redonner des
lettres de noblesse à l'université une
sélection peut être intéressante
donc je reste pour l'instant partagé
fait à partir du master peut-être une
solution peut-être fonction des
résultats des résultats qui sont
obtenues sur des craintes aussi au
niveau de tout ce qui est père
d'identité regarde d'autonomie aussi
parce que là on voit déjà que le logo
alors le hollow mais le logo à les voix
qui a plus tard il aura pu écrit
versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines
juste écrit ubs q qu'est ce que le côté
yvelinois va pas perdre un peu de son
identité
j'ai posé la question à l'inde hui dans
l'extrait que l'on a vu lui dit
effectivement le
en tout cas la marque ubs qu va
disparaître au sein de cette université
paris saclay mais les campus sylvie noir
vont bien demeurer sahim l'assurent ils
seront même renforcés
sandy casar ont été qui ont été
contestées engagées sur réhabilitation
de l'iut de vélizy aussi dans cette
perspective construction aussi du
premier bâtiment du futur campus de
mantes la jolie kim sears qui aussi qui
est aussi prévu alors tout se perd
université de versailles saint quentin
elle pourrait disparaître en tout cas
l'appellation peut-être et yveline aussi
peut-être disparaître s'il ya une fusion
aussi puisqu'on parle de tout fusionner
et tous rapprochés
c'est l'autre sujet qui va nous
intéresser maintenant pour ce club de la
presse toujours à suivre sur tv 78 tlfm
avec les avec aussi la participation de
toutes les nouvelles actus.fr c'est 8
actus.fr parlons de cette fusion
yvelines hauts de seine est ce qu'elle
est déjà actée est-ce qu'elle aura lieu
en 2020 il ya une nouvelle étape le 6
février il y aura une concertation
citoyenne sur le sujet par internet
fusion tirer 78-80 12 point fr à quoi va
servir cette cette consultation cette
concertation via chacun pourra exprimer
sa sont ces remarques en tout cas il y
aura pas une la question sera posée êtes
vous pour ou contre la fusion est ce qu
il aurait peut-être fallu déjà cette
question là il y aura d'autres
problématiques qui seront qui seront
abordés mais ce que cette question sera
essentiel à poser un qui m'a par exemple
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est que
on avait reçu les deux présidents des
départements lors d'une émission savoir
pire à bédié et patrick devedjian et on
avait posé expressément cette question
alors il ya quatre ans en 2016
on leur avait demandé si justement
peut-être qu effectué sept
ce sondage sonder la population était
intéressant pour eux est alors c'était à
l'époque absolument hors de propos donc
les temps ont évolué visible visiblement
leed
on a le sentiment en tant qu'observateur
que on arrive à une phase au il faut
tout donner
donc maintenant effectivement peut-être
que c'est devenu de propos et met la
pression sur le gouvernement
oui c'est aussi la pression est tout à
fait là montré que élus et les
populations sont pour pour l'instant je
ne suis pas convaincu lien pas
l'impression que ce soit le sujet de
mobilisation des élus les habitants j'ai
pas l'impression qu'ils soient
pleinement concernée par ce sujet la
soirée de la mesure de cette fusion
éventré les concertations se pensent ça
peut être un bon indicateur ou pas on
verra s'il ya une participation des
délits mineurs et d alto séquanais en
tout cas moi j'ai l'impression que les
enjeux départementaux c'est pas la
première priorité des habitants on voit
la participation aux élections
départementales c'est pas la meilleure
des participations en jusqu'au cou ce
qui est paradoxal parce que après le
département un rôle quand même essentiel
avec les collectivités locales pour
mener à bien des projets réagi voilà la
gestion des collèges ceci passe par le
départ de volet social
l'argument l'argument clé je pense ça
sera l'argument économique à savoir les
économies éventuelles potentiel réalisé
par cette fusion jeu 6 s'il ya un
argument décisif au niveau de la
population ça peut être que celui là
puisque comme vous le dites
effectivement la population encore très
attachés en tout cas une bonne
lisibilité des compétences et du rôle
d'un de leurs départements respectifs
en cas de fusion c'est vrai que nous
même je me rappelle en 2016 quand on a
vu ce projet annoncé on s'est posé la
question du devenir et les compétences
de ces super département sur 7 sur cette
concertation qui dit où s'ouvre sur
internet à partir du 6 février pour vous
donner aussi les informations donc ces
fusions tirer 78-80 12 point fr il n'y a
pas cette question qui est posée pour ou
contre la fusion il y aura des thèmes
qui seront abordés c'est ce qu'on nous
annonce développement économique emploi
innovation mobilité environnement et
cadre de vie sociale solidarité ruralité
culture et patrimoine et puis la scène
aussi sa gestion par les natures
économie et tourisme par exemple est
tout même une précision il semblerait
que en cas de fusion les deux présidents
de départements soient mis d'accord le
chef lieu du département reste dans les
yvelines ce serait versailles flore est
logique c'est logique à versailles est
beaucoup plus central que nanterre il ya
une histoire derrière en terme d'image
où il a mentionné mentionné devoir se
mettre aussi d'accord sur un numéro de
département alors il ya une anecdote
assez amusante lors de l'audition des
deux présidents à l'assemblée nationale
patrick devedjian a parlé du département
98 lorsque c'est un élément de langage
ou un simple lapsus révélateur en tout
cas c'est d'avoir le numéro du
département pourquoi pas 80 18 78 92
notre chienne grégory avait 98 sur rai
tv 98 ans remplacera tvt 78 vous parliez
alexandre tout à l'heure de mettre la
pression aussi sur le gouvernement il ya
aussi l'enjeu de la métropole du grand
paris puisque les deux présidents
veulent aussi bousculer un peu les
lignes et pleinement et associés yvin
hauts-de-seine et que les comptes ou
régionaux ne soit fasse pas en fonction
de la petite couronne
j'aimerais qu'on écoute les deux
présidents des départements 78 92
il pourrait y avoir un bloc
communautaire qui fait que le jour où on
élit ses conseillers départ tout autour
on peut aussi choisir un système qui
permettrait d'avoir des conseillers
communautaires parmi enfin des
conseillers métropolitaine pardon parmi
ses conseillers départementaux de façon
à voir là le bloc metropolitan la région
disparaît en tant que région elle se
transforme en métropole c'est à dire que
c'est elle qui aura la responsabilité
stratégique de l'organisation du
territoire métropolitain et avec en
particulier tout ce qui touche aux
transports deuxièmement le logement qui
est une préoccupation très prégnante à
l'ile-de-france et troisièmement les
solidarités territoriales
j'attends d'eux
du gouvernement qui a déjà fait
transparaître son sentiment qu'il règle
la question de définitivement de la
métropole
en instituant le fait qu'elle recouvre
la région et non plus le périmètre
riquiqui de la petite couronne et
clivant j'aimerais quand même votre avis
aux uns et aux autres on parlait un
moment de d'évoquer on évoquait la
simplification des différentes strates
de l'administration entre les régions
les départements il était même question
de fuseaux nié tout ça de faire
disparaître département voyons là
aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression qu'on s'y
retrouve encore moins on parle de grande
couronne de petit couronne de métropole
du grand paris de fusions de
départements ce que les gens s'y
retrouvent déjà ce que vous vous y
retrouvez
normalement c'est compliqué parce que
vous êtes à l'heure c'est pour ça que je
pense que la population se sent pas
concerné ça ajoute encore une strate au
millefeuille administratif et feuilles
vraiment territoriale il ya la région
les départements les intercommunalités
vous y rajoutez l'établissement public
d'aménagement paris saclay à côté de
notre territoire les pnr il ya plein de
plein de strates
effectivement on sapers à perdre les
habitants ça nous permet aux
journalistes on a on a du mal à se
plonger dans les dossiers à bien
comprendre tous les enjeux faut vraiment
beaucoup de beaucoup de travail et de
patience vous fait très tôt le matin
pour travailler tout ça pour le journal
chaque soir et puis on parlait aussi des
différentes fusions ya les fusions de
communes aux siens ces gens je aussi
pour faire des économies
le chesnay a fusionné avec rot concours
par exemple ce qui perd peut-être encore
plus la population
on verra une fois de plus pendant les
élections comment ça se traduit
d'ailleurs on peut mentionner brièvement
les municipales sont du côté du chéné du
côté de saint germain pour la première
fois il y aura des élections groupées
avec les nouvelles communes qui ont été
qui ont été créés
continuons ce tour d'horizon de
l'actualité pour ce club de la presse
avec un bras de fer entre le département
et le cimentier calcia on parle encore
du département des yvelines et de son
président pierre bédier qui a eu un gros
coup de colère début janvier contre le
cimentier calcia ces entreprises
implantées à guerville un village proche
de mantes-la-jolie qui souhaite
transférer le site de nanterre dans les
hauts-de-seine dont le courant de
l'année
les explications plus de détails avec ce
sujet d'aurélie rose colère et trahisons
pour pierre bédier président du
département des yvelines
il dénonce l'attitude de l'entreprise
calcia qui annonce
la délocalisation de son siège social
dans les hauts-de-seine sans en avertir
le département nous avons été trahis par
cette société et par des patrons voyous
qui au mépris de la parole donnée au
mépris des engagements pris et au mépris
des salariés de l'entreprise organise un
départ en catimini du territoire sur
lequel il ne laisserait que les
activités polluantes et tout ça pour
mener un plan social qui ne dit pas son
nom puisque à l'instant où je vous parle
on fait pression sur les salariés pour
les amener à démissionner puisque on les
déménage à plus de 30 km la société
calcia l'intention d'exploiter une
nouvelle carrière dans le vexin et
organise son départ vers rueil malmaison
un événement qui vient fragiliser
l'emploi local et qui attise
l'indignation des élus
en ce qui me concerne la confiance est
tout à fait rompu donc même si on a des
promesses avant le jeudi après midi
moi je rentre maintenant résolument dans
l'opposition acacias parce que ses
promesses même si elle arrive avant
jeudi
elles ne peuvent être que de papier ce
sont des promesses qui engage une
construction industrielle lourde qui
engagent des engagements sur la carrière
est lourd et je pense que même si les
prennent pour deux ans pour trois ans
dans trois ans on aura le même problème
la confiance est donc rompue
pierre bédier a annoncé qu'il
demanderait jeudi 16 janvier une
révision du plan local d'urbanisme
intercommunal pour interdire
l'exploitation de la nouvelle carrière à
bruille en vexin hakim après les faits
mme vous la comprenez cette colère oui
oui effectivement là on la comprend on a
suivi ce dossier évidemment c'était déjà
un dossier sensible puisque les élus en
certain nombre d'élus étaient en
opposition et craintif vis-à-vis des des
retombées
environnementales écologiques et alors
avec ce coup de théâtre
effectivement les responsables
les responsables du département et de la
gps au se sont retrouvés en porte à faux
donc on comprend effectivement cette
colère du coup le on arrive à pas de
siège social pas de pas de carrière
voilà donc effectivement servi à votre
titre
le bras de fer voilà voilà ce qu'on va
pu suivre effectivement et puis on a eu
philippe tautou aussi qui annonçait une
possible révision du pays à l'ue pour
maintenir justement cette cette pression
et puis la position de la présidente de
la région valérie pécresse qui va
demander l'arrêt du projet à l'état et
donc une opposition à présent vu qu'il
n'y a pas de compensation par le
maintien de l'emploi qui est un enjeu
essentiel sur le sur le territoire qui
est touchée de manière significative par
par le chômage la toul et tous les
responsables politiques effectivement se
braquent les salariés aussi au milieu de
tout ça s'inquiète un peu parce qu'il
parle d'une position à ce dur
effectivement on l'a entendu de la part
du département des différents élus et la
question c'est est ce qu'il n'aurait pas
fallu être un peu plus modérée pour
permettre de sauver quelques emplois ou
permettre des transferts d'emplois oui
si certains salariés c'est une question
là on la comprend effectivement en tout
cas en tout cas concernant la
délocalisation la délocalisation devrait
concerner au moins deux tiers des postes
avec 1 26 ans simplement d'un tiers sur
le site de guerville et puis il ya alors
moi ce que j'ai entendu aussi au delà de
l'aspect trahison c'est ce plan ce plan
social en catimini là là dessus on a pas
on a pas encore d'informations du côté
de l'entreprise calcia qui n'a pas
répondu à nos demandes donc on sait pas
ce qui se trame encore là dessous
avec elle c'est un front commun pendant
des élus on a vu dans le reportage
pierre bédier le président les
républicains des yvelines le sénateur la
république en marche martin lévriers
aussi le préfet des yvelines qui s'est
saisi du dossier donc c'est vrai qu'on a
il ya un front commun en tout cas des
représentants
il présente en politique vous que l'état
va sûrement revoir sa position sur le
sujet ce qu'est ce qui est très étonnant
quand même c'est de voir le président
bédié pour rouler dans la farine on
n'est pas habitué on est prudemment
c'est quand même un expert en politique
en négociation et tout ça à le voir des
arbres l'eau de rose et un peu par un
groupe allemand ça c'est très attendu sa
colère et il a évoqué des patrons voyous
c'est des mots forts qu'il est qu'il a
employés on comprend sa colère d'avoir
le sentiment de s'être fait un petit peu
à voir
tu avais raison alexandre c'est
paraissent pas souvent que ça arrive
dans le département des yvelines pierre
bédier d'état depuis quand même quelques
années et expérimenté en politique et il
a plutôt montré par le passé qu'il
maîtrisait ce genre de dossier là la
réponse du pdg de calyssia il s'est
exprimé tout de même pour ceux qui nous
suivent sur tv 60,18 vous le voyez en
photo derrière une photo extraite du
parisien il s'est exprimé tout de même
dans le parisien il comprend pas cette
réaction des différents élus édicules le
site est vieillissant donc il faut le
moderniser qu'il est pas facile d'accès
pour ses différents clients aussi et il
parle pas de plan social justement lundi
que les salariés vont partir à nanterre
et qui à 128 salariés qui devraient
rester sur le site du département
voilà pour l'instant du côté du côté de
calcia dit ne pas comprendre et du côté
des élus on l'a compris cette colère et
qui s'exprime voilà nous fermons cette
séquence liés à l'actualité au cours de
chacune des éditions du club de la
presse nous revenons aussi sur celles et
ceux qui font l'actualité dans le
département notre rubrique personnalité
du mois et on va commencer avec vous
alexandre remarquer pour toutes les
nouvelles actus.fr 7,8 actus.fr ça un
italien alors je vous préviens tout de
suite cette attention la renonciation à
la cannelle et face à vous faire
attention dans une personnalité du mois
c'est en fait notre illinois de l'année
des amis beaucoup des responsables il
s'appelle giulio scaramozzino
c'est pas mal ok les pizzaïolos il est
chef la pizzeria au bottega versailles
dans le quartier saint louis est en fait
sa particularité c'est qu'il est devenu
pizzaïolo sur le tard il ya dix ans
quand il arrivait en france est depuis
en fait
sa pizza a été élu parmi les trois
meilleures pizzas d'île de france et il
fait aussi de la pizza acrobatique et la
prochainement en mars il va participer
au championnat de france de pizza son
voile et ceux qui nous suivent donc sur
télé 78 du coup sûr l fm je renvoie vers
le replay de cette émission on pouvoir
la consulter on le voit en train de se
piquer à yolo en train de faire de la
pizza acrobatique grégory vous savez
faire ça vous avez notre consultant
pizzaïolo si je peux défend qui rentrait
au patrimoine immatériel de l'unesco
très récemment c'est vrai ça fait et
donc chaque année on organise un
concours dit les mois de l'année est
derrière lui il a su mobiliser ses amis
et même d'italie on avait des
internautes qui sont mobilisés en italie
pour voter pour lui et donc avec 1300
voix il a été élu évinois tannée et ça
vient top 3 dans ce palmarès je sais -
quels sont les autres un petit peu alors
je sais que pour le courrier des
yvelines c'était
et quelqu'un qui se battait contre les
déchets je crois qu'un sopo s'est
réalisé et effectivement on voit qui est
quand même un thème autour de
l'environnement puisque celui qui arrivé
deuxième derrière lui et c'était michael
et saunier président des marcheurs kaya
qui se bat aussi pour la protection de
l'environnement autour de zombies wiki
organiser encore une mobilisation
quelques jours de ramassage de déchets
sont ramassés plus d'une tonne de
déchets il alerte les différents
candidats aux élections municipales où
il ya c'est donc c'est un thème qui
touche les gens d'ailleurs pour revient
sur le sort l'actualité aussi des
municipales quel que soit le candidat et
quel que soit le programme ya toujours
cette sensibilité-là d'écologie
d'environnement de transition écologique
qui qui traverse tous les programmes et
toutes les thématiques vous le verrez de
vous rendre c'était plutôt une valeur de
gauche est finalement là tous les
candidats ont les candidats par votre
succès c'est aussi dans la ligne et
peut-être des résultats aux élections
européennes on a vu les bons résultats
des écologistes notamment en france du
côté de télé 78 à présent pour la
personnalité de ce mois ci grégory ce
sera une couturière mais elle est de
l'australie
c'est ça s'appelle marie pierre allouche
alors elle n'est pas président de cette
association mais bénévole au sein de
l'association culture et loisirs de
saint léger en yvelines est donc cette
bénévole dans la section couture a
proposé à ses coéquipières ses
coéquipiers de constituer quelques sacs
poche pour les koalas les bébés
kangourous blessés on rappelle qu'il ya
eu plus d'un milliard d'animaux qui sont
morts quand cette catastrophe
incendies en australie et donc elle a
répondu marie pierre alooshe et les
bénévoles de cette section couture à
l'appel du collectif animal rescue croft
guilde pardon pour l'accent anglais
voilà qui demande un accent qui mordait
voilà l'envoi de
en tout cas de petites créations
couturière pour aider les animaux à tel
point que il ya eu un il vraiment une
mobilisation mondiale ils se sont
retrouvés avec trop de produits sur
place donc pour l'instant ils ont freiné
les envoie les envois de couture de
produits couturier on écoute
marie-pierre à gauche justement de cette
association on s'est dit bon on fait
notre part du colibri
voilà c'est oui c'est long à l'australie
oui on va pas sauver la planète
notre famille on s'est dit on va on va
faire ce qu'il faut pour un autre mesure
à la mesure de ce qu'on peut faire et
des petits groupes de coups durs grand
nez et bien participé aussi à ça nous
avons besoin et c'est important pour
nous mais voilà ces images pour ceux qui
nous rejoignent sur télé 78 derrière de
l'australie en feu il ya une
mobilisation parler de cette opération
menée par une association de couture et
qui sera réelle concrète sur le terrain
et des pompiers aussi qui sont
mobilisées dans le département
vous l'avez rappelé leurs antennes
alexandre qui vont partir des pompiers
qui sont là qui partent bénévolement et
même à me lancer une cagnotte en ligne
vous l'avez constaté cette solidarité et
d'autres opérations dans le département
les uns les autres
moi j'ai pas suivi sur du côté de l fm
radio effectivement d'une dizaine de
pompiers tout le département et de
l'eure-et-loir qui vont qui vont partir
des pieds des yvelines de l'eure et loir
est accompagné d'un caméraman donc on
pourra aussi revenir sur leurs leurs
opérations qui débute le 6 février
s'envole le 6 février pour l'australie
chine accueille les cagnottes qui sont
en ligne on appelle tout de même à la
vigilance aussi de ce qui est celle qui
nous suivent ne donnez pas sur n'importe
quel cagnotte voilà essayé il ya
toujours des malheureusement des petits
malins on va dire ça comme ça ou des
voyous pour reprendre l'expression du
président du département et qui décide
de s'enrichir de suez les fonds ne vont
pas sur le terrain vaut privilégier les
actions concrètes qui sont menés on a
évoqué cette opération menée par
l'association de marie-pierre allouche
et rechercher son association culture et
loisirs et donc marie pierre lellouche
et bénévoles aussi un os un pardon de la
section couture ya différentes sections
ça c'est au sein de cette association de
saint léger en yvelines très bien du
côté de l fm à présent provost acquis ma
personnalité
c'était une femme pour évidemment une
l'après zine présidents d'associations
également l'association au coeur
de la fraternité elle s'appelle khadija
s'assied et on a reçu pour faire le
bilan de quatre années quatre années au
service des sdf et des familles les plus
démunies de mantes-la-jolie et du
mantois
c'est une mère de famille qui travaille
par ailleurs à l'hôpital et qui consacre
la majorité de son temps libre avec sa
famille même ses enfants pour distribuer
des colis alimentaires est là pour
l'organisation de maraude toute la
semaine
pour donner un ordre d'idée ça donne 50
mille repas distribués par an depuis
2000 16 est ce qu'on a appris aussi lors
de ce plateau c'est une augmentation des
besoins et malheureusement une baisse
des moyens humains et du nombre de
bénévoles et d'ailleurs on l'écoutait
justement dans une certaine difficulté
en même temps une volonté de ne pas
lâcher on va l'écouter mais justement
alors je vous assure que des fois c'est
pas facile quand on n'a pas beaucoup de
bénévoles sur l'action quand on les
invendus sont très peu et que
il faut aller courir aller acheter les
denrées qui monte parce qu on a 35 colis
à faire dans leur cas qui arrive
les familles sont déjà en route pour
arriver chercher leur colis des fois oui
des fois c'est vrai que c'est difficile
mais
on ne lâchera pas ils ont besoin de nous
ils ont besoin de nous et voilà c'est
pas du mobilier urbain
il peut arriver à tout le monde il faut
pas hésiter à aider son prochain
ne serait-ce qu'un euro comme nous on
dit un euro c'est un euro un show elle
va peut-être que c'est rien pour vous
mais prusse et beaucoup
pourquoi elle a décidé de s'engager
comme ça pas aux côtés des restos du
coeur par exemple ou d'autres
associations
alors c'est une initiative absolument
personnelle familiale
ils sont partis suite à il était
spectateur de ce qui se passait alors
c'était au moment de l'afflux de
réfugiés pas d'abord dans le mantois
mais du côté de saint denis et ils se
sont ils se sont spontanément lancé dans
une opération de distribution et ils
sont retrouvés d'ailleurs rapidement à
cours et puis en s'intéressant ce qui se
passait dans le secteur du mantois ils
sont rendus compte que tous les secteurs
n'était pas forcément couvert et d'où la
volonté de contribuer mais de manière
autonome indépendante j'imagine même
s'il ya quand même une concertation de
ces différentes associations notamment
sur le roulement est à dire que eux sont
présents deux à trois fois par semaine
sur la collège devant la collégiale de
mantes la jolie
donkey ceux entre guillemets se marche
pas dessus les poubelles d'associations
comme ça des initiatives qui se monte à
travers le département
est ce qu'on peut dire c'est à plaisir
par exemple si
l'association malines et milou qui agit
aussi dans le sens et des jeunes de
jeanne duval ebooks ont créé leur
association qui sont mobilisés avec des
amis de toute l'ile-de-france si les
argonnais de réfugiés qui ont été
accueillis voilà ils ont aidé à
villepreux ils ont aidé à cher ils
interviennent aussi sur toutes les
portes de paris aubervilliers stalingrad
ils sont présents toute l'année toute
l'année c'est des jeunes vivalib ou au
départ qui ont décidé de se mobiliser
pour en revenir à votre personnalité du
moins qui m'a pour la contacter pour
l'aider par exemple oui ils ont un site
absolument au coeur de la fraternité
point fr et d'ailleurs il organise un
gala caritatif à mantes-la-jolie au parc
des expos lille aumône le 15 février
prochain pour les personnes qui sont
intéressées à elle profitait aussi pour
annoncer cet événement est attendu ils
sont à la recherche de bénévoles
et alors il ya une notion qui était
intéressante on lui a posé une question
assez simple c'est qu'elle quel temps on
doit avoir devant nous pour s'investir
en tant que bénévole à ce qu'il faut
pouvoir libérer une fois par semaine
j'imagine qu'il ya plein de
téléspectateurs d'auditeurs qui peuvent
se demander dans quelle mesure ils
peuvent aider
et alors ils sont assez souples ainsi
vous avez une disponibilité une fois par
mois par exemple eh ben on peut on peut
effectivement se porter candidat et
avoir un petit geste
ces citoyens et sociales minutes
accordées par les uns et les autres qui
permettra à ces différentes associations
notamment c'est à vous à nous a bluffés
par à part son engagement sac c'est une
personnalité du mois on passe à notre
dernière séquence du club de la presse
pour ce mois-ci bientôt à la une le club
de la presse tv 78 sur l fm également en
partenariat avec toutes les nouvelles
7,8 à cu.fr pour ce mois-ci l'actualité
à suivre sur les prochaines semaines
alexandre vous allez consacré un dossier
un petit peu moins sujet à la lutte
contre le harcèlement
du côté de plaisir oui on va faire un
sujet sur les bancs de l'amitié donc
c'est un concept original qui a été mis
en place par la ville de plaisir depuis
quelques semaines en fait la ville a
installé des bancs dans chacune de ses
27 écoles élémentaires et en fait
l'idéal est simple c'est si un enfant on
cherche à se faire des amis il s'assoit
juste sur le banc et l'objectif en fait
c'est de lutter contre l' isolement et
contre les harcèlements et puis de
résoudre les conflits entre les élèves
donc c'est un concept en fait que
qu'inspiré des états unis où ça existe
depuis une dizaine d'années qu'ils
viennent bien aux états unis et qui
fonctionne aux états unis en france
c'est des prémices je sais pas trop ce
que ça va donner mais là on pour être
sûr ceux sur l'exemple de plaisir pour
nous être rendus également en hausse y
étions allés pour un reportage portée
des 70 dit ça fonctionnait plutôt bien
et des enfants qui expliquait ben voila
je me suis disputé avec un copain je
suis allé m'asseoir et puis
effectivement on vient me chercher on
vient me voir et une certaine
bienveillance entre les enfants
donc c'est bien de commencer comme ça et
ça marche plutôt bien et c'est à plaisir
mais il y en a aussi dans d'autres dans
d'autres secteurs
or les yvelines qui s'organise ce genre
d'opération pour lutter contre le
harcèlement en tout cas être
bienveillant là ce sera le mot à
employer
du côté de l fm bientôt à la lune chez
vous la banlieue du refus c'est ça on a
été chassé un petit peu sur vos terres
parce que c'est alors je suis peut-être
quelque chose vous la laissiez découvrir
ah oui
et pourtant ce n'est pas le coût de la
vie maclin fofana dans l'émission on a
retrouvé dans on en parle donc c'est un
jeune habitant du quartier du bois de
l'étang à la verrière étudiants en
design et chercheurs lui les fondateurs
de l'hyper cube et on le reçoit pour
parler de ce laboratoire qui tue les
l'hyper cube qui soit ouvrir une
réflexion collaborative sur l'avenir de
la banlieue alors nous on a trouvé ça
passionnant puisque nos étudiants sont
basés au coeur du val fourré il ya en
gros l'idée c'est d'imaginer le futur
des grands ensembles à travers le design
la fiction ou voir même la science
fiction tout un tout un programme à
retrouver dans quinze jours du real fm
radio pour parler de la banlieue du
refus et puis bien évidemment nous
voulons ce sujet et n'hésitez pas à en
parler prochainement voilà c'est aussi
ça dans les médias on s'observe aussi
donc c'est une belle initiative et qui
mérite d'être valorisé bravo d'avoir
d'avoir repéré ce jeune makan fofana
d'habitants du quartier du bois de
l'étang à la verrière et la banlieue du
refus voilà bientôt sur votre tv 60 18
de notre côté ce seront les débats des
premiers tours des municipales
je vous en donne quelques indications il
y aura 20 débat à compter du 8 février
de week end en direct et deux
rediffusions ensuite à 20 heures tout au
long de la semaine les différentes
communes de saint quentin en yvelines de
saint cyr l'école manque la ville de
mantes la jolie et rambouillet
versailles les mureaux saint germain en
laye seront donc à l'honneur des débats
entre une demi-heure et une heure pour
que chacun expose programme et
propositions à suivre aussi en replay
sur notre site notre application
il ya certains également débat qui ne
seront pas à manquer en est que des
communes particulière même si vous ne
résidez pas sur ces communes où il ya
des enjeux malgré tout et des débats qui
devraient être intéressant sur trappe
villepreux guyancourt grégory je me
tourne vers vous aussi versailles puis
manque la ville qui devrait être à
suivre un débat des débats qu'ils se
rassurent donc sur notre antenne vous
aurez bien sûr tous les renseignements
pratiques sur notre site internet
et si vous avez d'ores et déjà des
questions aussi que vous souhaitez poser
aux candidats si vous souhaitez les
interpellés au cours de cette campagne
vous pouvez utiliser nos réseaux sociaux
et nous nous relèverons à tout cela au
cours des prochaines semaines et une
fois tout cela passe et il y aura des
soirées électorales 15 et 22 mars à
partir de 19h30 sur notre antenne pour
suivre en direct les différents
résultats dans le département des
yvelines pour les autres médias quels
sont vos dispositifs un petit peu hakim
assurer les femmes pour ça
pour ces municipales où ça se passera
essentiellement sur notre morning et
puis sur le programme de la pause actu
donc à 12h01
on a détaché 15 minutes par tête de
liste voilà ce qu'on a ce qu'on a prévu
pour pour le secteur pour les grandes
villes de heavy nord du département
alexandre à nous on en parle dans toutes
nos éditions régulièrement des
différents candidats et il ya de quoi
faire avec quatre ou cinq candidats en
général par un parent ville et puis le
soir même et on axera sur des villes
importantes comme versailles rambouillet
ou bien sur l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines trappe par exemple
il ya un gros enjeu commune c'est comme
une nation à suivre l'actualité c'est au
quotidien sur nos différents médias
poursuivre cette campagne des
municipales rappel c'est important
d'aller voter aussi vous choisissez
votre mère même si on le sait la
participation plutôt bonne en tout cas
les les gens s'impliquent c'est l'élu de
proximité le maire donc forcément on
passe aux différentes unes des nouvelles
à la une des nouvelles éditions de
versailles alexandre sera le début de
campagne justement de françois de
mazières
oui il brigue un troisième mandat les
grandissimes favoris à sa réélection et
face à lui devrait retrouver pour
l'instant on est à 6 10 déclaré devrait
y en avoir une
une septième avec le front national mais
oui il y a priori je pense qu'il aura
pas trop de soucis à se faire pour un
forçat de mazières le maire qui a de
nouveau sortant qui est à nouveau
candidat et puis à la une de l'édition
de rambouillet pour toutes les nouvelles
les quatre listes qui s'affrontent cette
fois ci du côté du perray-en-yvelines
sera aussi question dans cette édition
du transfert du siège du parc naturel de
la vallée de chevreuse le nouveau site
qui a été retenu s'étaient annoncées par
valérie pécresse la présidente de région
d'ailleurs c'est la ferme de bord c'est
au mesnil saint denis ou encore quelques
travaux à faire et ce sera pas pour les
prochains mois sera plutôt pour les
prochaines années
voilà pour le déménagement du pnr à
venir merci d'avoir participé à ce club
de la presse marcillac himaya donc
rédactrice en chef et les femmes
alexandre marquet responsable de secteur
notamment sur saint quentin en yvelines
pour toutes les nouvelles calme en
présence sur internet le 7-8 actus.fr et
puis grégory canal et rédacteur en chef
adjoint de téléphiles on se retrouvera
au mois de mars pour le prochain club de
la presse puisque vous l'avez compris
elle est là les élections vont nous
occuper d'ici là on vous retrouve très
prochainement sur l'antenne de télé 78
[Musique]